We're doing a tea tasting.
Tea is one of my favourite things.
Lucky just got around to it a while ago.
My sister ordered from this tea company called Tea Pigs,
and they have so many different flavours,
so I had to order some and it got a little out of.
So now I'm making lucky try all of them.
Just a little out of hand here.
These are all the teas we're working with.
Spiced pear, rhubarb, ginger,
lemon, ginger,
chocolate, mint,
red winter tea, apple, cinnamon,
roybis caramel. And the red fruit tea.
This is roybis cream caramel.
It smells so good to me. I love a good,
robust tea. It's one of my favourite teas ever.
Stunning. Just stunning.
We didn't sweeten any of them.
And usually
lucky likes his tea so sweet that you don't even know what the tea is.
So I'm curious how this is gonna go.
Good. It's good.
Six and a half. Oh, okay.
This tea is ginger rhubarb. So interesting.
Tart. That's actually really good. Holy crap.
4. This is solid eight for me. Four.
Have you ever had rhubarb, though?
No. Okay, okay,
that makes sense. Lemon, ginger.
Lucky has very high hopes.
High hopes.
I'm underwhelmed.
Very underwhelmed. This is water.
To me, it tastes like hot water.
What did we mix it?
Mediocre. A one out of 10.
Wow, that's pretty low.
What is it for you? It's literally just water.
Oh, this one's next.
What's this one? Oh,
spiced winter red tea. It smells very like cinnamon.
Like warm. It smells very warm,
like winter, you know?
Really taste the cinnamon?
I can really taste the red.
Um. Yep,
yep,
yep. Seven out of 10 or six.
Apple cinnamon. Oh,
I'm excited. I used to drink apple tea when I was younger all the time,
so I'm excited for this one.
Apple tea, you guys,
is so underrated. That's a nine out of 10.
That's so good. You can taste the apple.
The cinnamon is literally just the tiniest hint.
That's nice. You like it?
Eight out of 10.
Wow. Chocolate mint.
It smells like mint chocolate to me, which is concerning.
That tastes like mint chocolate.
Holy crap. Yes, I.
I mean, if you like mint chocolate.
Yeah. It's doing what it's supposed to be doing.
It's good, though.
Red fruit.
I love a fruity Berry tea.
These are very nostalgic as well.
Berry tart. Yes,
you can. It's very Berry tart.
Not sweet at all. You don't like that?
Don't like it. That's a solid seven.
No, no, no.
Spiced pear. I actually.
I'm not gonna lie. I had this the other night.
It was really good. It's.
I'm gonna let you try it first, actually,
cause it's very surprising.
I like it. That's an 8 for me. Okay.
Do you get this spice? Yep.
Like, you swallow it and you just feel the spice.
I think it has chili in it.
It's very warm. If you don't like spicy,
I wouldn't get it. So what was your favorite one?
The spicy one. Really?
Yeah.
Okay. What's your second favourite?
I don't remember. Rhubarb and ginger one was a surprising underdog.
Like, I didn't think I would like it,
and I really enjoyed it. Um,
I'm gonna have the rest of these teas.